Helder what he said he says in order to
bring the change you have to free the
land every single portion of this land
is owned by corporations is owned by
banks big change has to come you know
when I look out here I'm happy to see
the numbers that are here what I really
want to see is at least 10,000 people
running around this place I was talking
to me to see how many are these big
factories here oh yeah I didn't expect
me to concentrate in such a small space
I'm shocked that there are First Nations
who are living here
we've been hearing all the media of all
these pipes breaking and waterways
getting damaged and we just not going to
accept that risk